purpose of this thing that we call the
world I think is to send us
synchronicities or send us experiences
that help us unravel that stuff mm-hmm
and a lot of times we get sent
situations which should make us trigger
us with those kind of wounds that we
have and but it's an opportunity for us
to unravel them and change them so I
think we had the opportunity to grow and
change and become better versions of
ourselves and uplevel our game my my
mother coming to the United States and
birthing me here triggered a completely
different tree as possibility than if I
was born in Yerevan in Armenia
completely different right and maybe
there's a point at which on her journey
you know a few months before she left
for the United States where it was a
really fine line between what she was
gonna choose yes and we can look at that
situation and say okay every other day
the decision of whether she got up in
the morning and went to look out the
window was inconsequential but on one
particular day she got up and looked out
the window and it was a beautiful day
and she got her mind set in her heart
that she was gonna make this change and
that led to her having an experience
that day which just it made her decide
to move and that led to you being born
here so down the road there's this
hugely different outcome we can look at
that one decision as meaningful not in a
subjective sense like you know it was
good or bad but in the sense of if you
look at this direction it's very very
different in the long run from this
direction is just a difference in the
types of experiences that happen from
that one choice point yes so we can
identify those as like the singular
moments in life when it's more crucial
how we approach a situation and what
decisions we make the picture that I
have in my worldview that's come to me
from like where I started trying to
understand the meaning of events in my
life we just talked about the meaningful
choices that we make and how you know
they decide what career we choose or
what country we live in
just who we become those are the
meaningful choices we makin and how do
they show up in our lives how do we make
those decisions what and then I started
doing research I've been studying for
decades is an interest in Fourier
transforms and Holograms I've at the
holographic universe by Michael Talbot
when I was a teenager and really
passionate and they'll work by David
Bohm in the implicit order and really
passionately trying to understand what
it could mean that the world is really
informational what it could mean that
consciousness comes first someone's
opinion may contradict yours
where's my friend Alan it's all about
your perspective who are we if what is
the nature of this reality what's up
everyone welcome to simulation I'm your
host Don sockin I'm very pumped to be
talking with sky Nelson Isaacs hi sky
hey Alan good to see you thanks so much
for coming on the program and I'm very
grateful to Seth Cossack for introducing
us so pumped so pumped yeah thanks for
the intro it's been great to meet you
Alan and find out more about what you're
doing and spreading lots of good
information and ideas and curiosity it's
what I love about you the most the
curiosity that you bring to the show
Thank You sky and it was so fascinating
when we began uncovering this such a
similar space of interest between us
you from a very physics oriented
standpoint and also integrating some of
that spirituality in there and me coming
at it from like a bunch of other areas
of thinking so we've really been able to
hit the ball back so well with each
other on this say you I even went as far
as authoring a book on it let's give a
quick background on sky so he's the
author of living in flow he got a
Russian science from Berkeley
physics and then a master science in
physics with a thesis on string theory
from San Francisco State University and
it's so cool when I get to dive into
depth on what you wrote because living
and flows all about the science of
synchronicity and how our choices shape
our world and we talk about this quite a
lot on the program regarding having a
constant decisions that we make that are
bifurcations in this beautiful tree that
the in the tree of possibility and all
these little bifurcating moments and you
and I went really hard on that
I wanna um we're gonna get into all of
that and we're gonna get into a lot more
I want to start with one of our favorite
questions to start the shows off with
which is ultimately what is the nature
of this reality what made it what's the
point of it what's her role in it that's
a great question and I'm not gonna
answer it but I'll talk about it and
that's been a question I've been curious
about my whole life the same as you and
what what I sort of realized pretty
early was that we're here to learn we're
here to grow and I was introduced to
traditions that have that as their
background you know I read the daodejing
in my teens and there was introduced to
Hinduism early on and of course I was
familiar with Christianity and Judaism
and Sufi Islam has been interesting to
me reading the poetry of Rumi all four
decades sacred to me I love it it's just
for me the beauty of life is around the
way in which events happen the way in
which life falls into place and it can
be really heartbreaking sometimes and
painful it can be really beautiful and
fun and exciting and all of it in some
sense is sacred as this as this aura of
you know why is this
in a certain way so what I feel about
that is that we're we're here to learn
and grow and and heal the parts of
ourselves that haven't been wounded and
we take on wounds when we're little I
think you know as we as we are kids we
take on other people's issues we respond
to situations that happen to us in
certain ways and those responses aren't
always the most healthy way to respond
right like if my parents ignore me at a
crucial time in my life I might feel
like I'm abandoned or something like
that
you know so I start to react to
different people in the same way with
that same pattern so I think we develop
patterns that are emotional patterns and
psychological patterns and the purpose
of life is or I don't like phrasing it
that way but the purpose of this thing
that we call the world I think is to
send us synchronicities or send us
experiences that help us unravel that
stuff mm-hmm and a lot of times we get
sent situations which make us trigger us
with those kind of wounds that we have
and but it's an opportunity for us to
unravel them and change them so I think
we have the opportunity to grow and
change and become better versions of
ourselves and uplevel our game yes yes
okay what a great way to kick us off so
this idea of this reality being a
creation of ourselves is something that
has been very interesting that we
ourselves are the creators we are all
that is we made this school that we are
understanding ourselves better in by
playing in the game and that I really
appreciated how you went back in terms
of ancient spiritualities of the world
the Taoism is the Hinduism's the great
philosophers and poets Rumi I would
highly recommend those that are
listening that haven't really dived into
ancient spirituality um to go and spend
a week or two of your life just on
Wikipedia studying the ancient
spiritualities of the world because I
think
that given the fact that we live in 2020
and that everyone thinks that all the
coolest [ __ ] is happening today I think
I think that that is actually a horrible
aspect of what it it's a beautiful
feature in the sense that it's drawing
so many people away from the ancient
spiritualities but it now it's our turn
to try and help people realize that so
much of the profundity of understanding
the nature of reality is actually not in
the 20/20 instantaneous news cycle but
it's actually in the old codes well
let's talk about the the DAO Cohen or
there's n Cohen if a tree falls in a
forest and no one is there to hear it
does it make a sound if you think about
if if this is a big if this is
controversial stuff if quantum mechanics
applies to the whole world if it's
universal and not just a tool we use on
the very microscopic things and that's
controversial theorem but it's this part
of the centre of my work if we can show
that that's the case then what quantum
mechanics says quantum mechanics is a
study of what the world is doing when
we're not watching it when you look at
an electron going through a magnetic
field that splits into one of two
different possible directions based upon
its spin and when you're not watching it
all you can say is that there's a
superposition of possibilities certain
statistical likelihood of one or the
other so what is the tree doing when
you're not watching it if the same rules
apply it's in a superposition of the
fallen and not fallen and so they were
seeming to describe the very same
conundrums that we came to in the early
20th century when we started studying
stuff at the microscopic level and
realizing that there's this intermediate
level there's there's reality as we know
it and then there's the void of
non-existence and that's all most people
think about but actually quantum
mechanics says is this in between level
of possibilities the wavefunction is
describing all the possibilities of
something and it's only when we measure
it that we get to this level of
existence and that's I think there's a
direct connection between us trying to
solve that problem and the early just
trying to solve the other problem others
didn't have the tools that we have and
that's the beautiful thing about the
knowledge we have today is we can apply
it to some of these ancient riddles yes
yes okay this is such a great way to
move us in okay um as as we get into the
hardcore cutting-edge sciences of
quantum mechanics in the way that those
actually are so deeply related with
ancient spiritualities I want us to also
a brush on what you were mentioning in
that intro segment around the complexity
of birth the the polarity of birth and
then the other polarity of death and
then the interval of life in between and
how you began touching on you you use
this word a pattern and and stimuli and
there's there's a lot that we take in
from even our ancestors our ancestral
lineage there's so much complexity over
the billions of years of evolution that
led to our birth where it is our we're
now starting to really understand at a
deeper level how much the microbiome
affects us and those are microbes that
have been around billions of years and
we're starting to understand more about
how epigenetically our ancestral lineage
we may be actually carrying significant
stress from our our ancestors or our
trauma from our ancestors but also some
of the great skills that they brought
forth maybe they themselves were were
engineers or they themselves were
designers of some sort or doctors or
teachers and so we carried that with us
so then there's the moment of birth when
you're actually beginning to take in all
the stimuli every second and how that
shapes your neural physiology your heart
your brain everything that now
now-now-now sky I'm so interested to
know where you know this tree of
possibility
we we ourselves let me let me give you
the example with me my my mother coming
to the United
dates and birthing me here triggered a
completely different tree of possibility
than if if I was born in Yerevan in
Armenia coma lately different right and
maybe there's a point at which on her
journey you know a few months before she
left for the United States where it was
a really fine line between what she was
gonna choose yes and we can look at that
situation and say okay every other day
the decision of whether she got up in
the morning and went to look out the
window was inconsequential but on one
particular day she got up and looked out
the window and it was a beautiful day
and she got her mind set in her heart
that she was going to make this change
and that led to her having an experience
that day which just it made her decided
to move and that led to you being born
here so down the road there's this
hugely different outcome and we can look
at that one decision as meaningful not
in a subjective sense like you know it
was good or bad but in the sense of if
you look at this direction it's very
very different in the long run from this
direction it's just just a difference in
the types of experiences that happen
from that one choice point yes so we can
identify those as like the singular
moments in life when it's more crucial
how we approach a situation and what
decisions we make now now could we I
really want to really want to ask this
question there's so many ways to go from
here could it be that everything
everything is perfect beautiful that's a
great great way to put it so that the
picture that I have in my worldview
that's come to me from like where I
started trying to understand the meaning
of events in my life we just talked
about the meaningful choices that we
make and how you know they decide what
career we choose or what country we live
in or just who we become those are the
meaningful choices we makin and how do
they show up in our lives how do we make
those decisions what and and then I
started doing research I've been
studying for
decades there's an interest in Fourier
transforms and Holograms I read the
holographic universe by Michael Talbot
when I was a teenager and really
passionate and the work by David Bohm on
the implicit order and really
passionately trying to understand what
it could mean that the world is really
informational what it could mean that
consciousness comes first what I mean by
that is if you take a second and stop
thinking about the world and notice that
you're actually experiencing the world
right now there's this thing called
experience and philosophers like David
Chalmers use the word qualia to describe
the qualitative experience that you
can't just you can't give it to anybody
else you can't say here's a code
describing my qualitative experience you
can only experience qualitative
experience and then you can I can tell
you the dinner I had of pasta last night
tasted you know divine and you would
have an imagination about what pastas
like because you've tasted it before mmm
but I couldn't actually convey to you
the information about the taste and the
sensation and the experience that I had
so my my sense is that we can't ever
explained in materialist terms what
qualia are what experiences we have to
start with that as the basis the basis
of reality is the aware experience we're
having of it and in that aware
experience we have a physical world
which unfolds and we can talk more about
the math underneath us if you want
unfolds like a hologram unfolds it's a
representation an informational
representation of data that shows up in
a physical form that you know is you can
feel you can touch you can see but
nonetheless what what differentiates a
holographic world from the world that we
think of normally is it in a holographic
world you don't have what you might call
object permanence like when a baby is
born coming back to your example they
come into the world and you give them a
toy and they play with the toy and you
take it away and they forget that the
toy exists
and that's a great example and it's also
the way video games are designed play a
multiplayer online video game you're
playing your game but the game is
actually in your computer it's not out
there in the world it's not even on a
central server anywhere it sits in your
laptop and it's being rendered for you
and it seems like there's this world out
there because other people are on their
laptops doing their thing but what's
really happening is a personal rendering
of the world and then sharing the
relevant sharing of information between
the worlds to make it seem like there's
a seamless world hmm and that's a great
model for how I think this holographic
multiverse that we're in works we're
experiencing a rendering of this
holographic information that exists in
what we what can be called frequency
space or the frequency domain and that's
rendering a sense of reality that has
mass and as touch as color has all those
things and gives us the sense that we
are existing in a physical world and it
is a physical world but it's primarily
information coming from the conscious
experience we're having first yes yes oh
okay
now we make us us creating this with the
ingenious of making it so that we have
an an individual a holographic rendering
that is happening for each one of us in
the massive multiplayer game that we're
in and then we have a shared reality
about the word cup and that cup being
filled with water and that we can say
please refill my cup and you know what
that means and then to do that so so
there's some there's some again there's
just there's so many interesting ways to
take it but I wanna I wanna I want to
stay with a couple things um coming back
again we have we have we have this is
probably one of the coolest words that
this in the world it's the word
bifurcation and I know as such it is
such a cool cold word I don't think I
could use that in the song though yeah
sound very good as a cold dark night and
our paths bifurcated yes or or um you
know like you will like we're describing
with you know these profound moments eat
for our our ancestors in our lineage um
you know we could make a coal love song
about that bifurcating moment about my
mom coming here rather than Armenia and
so and how important those choices are
now that we're making for our children
and their children and looking a little
bit and that's that's a key element of
the holographic formulation of the world
and quantum mechanics that I'm working
on is that instead of focusing on the
present moment which is what we're also
focused on you think that we live in the
present we actually are existing on a
timeline there is no present moment in
physics I in my understanding there are
timelines or branches of this tree that
bifurcate and so when we start to see
ourselves more on a timeline that has an
outcome we start to take a little bit
more risk least I should speak for
myself it gives me more context for what
I'm choosing and in the moment I might
feel feeling grumpy or morose or
whatever but when I look at the timeline
and where I'm going it gets me out of
that say okay I gotta focus on what's
the outcome I'm looking for and then
wait for them notice how the outcome is
giving me opportunities filling in the
path for me to get there and those are
what we call synchronicities the
opportunities to move forward in and the
meaningful path that we want to get onto
yes yes
now mmm you you bring up again something
that's just so pivotal crucial for us to
realize is that this this idea of like a
North Star or a as as we call in
computer science a MCTS a Monte Carlo
trees
that you go for this most distant fruit
of yours and that you really want to
achieve that fruit in terms of what
impact you want to make in the world
what value you want to bring to other
people etc your your your lineage that
you want to leave behind all these types
of things so and then if this is a a
multi-agent reinforcement learning
environment that that we find ourselves
in that then in order for us we can do
really interesting things like like sky
I can I can I can find a peak where that
fruit is that of a person that's at the
cutting edge of biotech or neuroscience
or AI or crypto and blockchain or
spirituality or whatever and I can I can
I can identify that and then I can make
crucial steps in order to attempt to get
mentors in that space there's so many
wasted rise up these are those
bifurcating moments are you going are
you going to focus hardcore on achieving
your fruit or are you going to maybe
want to go and you know party more are
you gonna want to watch more Netflix are
you gonna want to eat more processed
foods and refined sugars that are going
to kill you faster you're not gonna
sleep enough are you not going to
exercise enough so so I these are all
bifurcate moments and you can have small
ones like let's let's probably hit on
hit on this point then you buy for
kiddie moments can have a weight to them
that is lower than other bifurcating
moments so certain bifurcating moments
like that decision for my mom to come to
the US or for me to move to Silicon
Valley
those are larger weights then maybe my
one instance of eating a cupcake versus
not yeah right
and I think it's really useful really a
useful aspect of this way of
understanding the world is seeing these
things that happen in life with some
context so you talked about gaining a
mentor well maybe you're you're thinking
I want to be in this field I want to be
doing what I want to be a rock star I
want to be a computer programmer or
whatever it is and what happens is you
come across somebody who's not going to
get you anywhere but actually has some
things to teach you
and if you're paying attention you
notice that as an actual moment along
the path that's sent there to help you
it's responding to the choice you made
and the actions you've taken but it
doesn't look like you thought it would
you know you didn't realize you needed a
mentor you thought you needed a
breakthrough but what you really needed
was this person to come along and help
you see things a little differently so I
think it's really there's a sense of
humility that comes to me when I see
like oh yeah I think I need XYZ in order
to get where I want to go but actually
the situation's I'm being sent right now
are the very situations I need to get
where I want to go and that might be
like I've set my set my goal on you know
hitting half a million dollars in my you
know revenue this year or something like
that let's say that's not me but let's
say that that was my my business goal
and I'm trying to work my way up the
ladder and then something goes it
happens at home that I have to deal with
I really just can't avoid even though I
want to because I'm trying to focus on
this this goal I had yes yes that thing
happening at home is in service yes yes
yes it's all in service to that goal
yeah it's a trusting that okay I need to
divert my attention to this other place
I need to learn I need to deal with this
and understand myself at a deeper level
so that I can use that information to
get where I need to go it's probably one
of the most reoccurring themes on our
show with all the different people we
sit down with is that their greatest
traumas have led to their greatest
treasures and the it's almost as though
the faster that we realize that those
bifurcating moments that seem like
they're horrible diseases divor
is death
right there's all of these different
traumas that come up and for us to
realize that they actually serve us as
lessons in the school that we were first
referencing towards that fruit that's
been such a reoccurring theme it's
probably one of the top reoccurring
themes with all the people that we sit
down with like if if we could if we
could like wave a big like wand and try
and like pass along a profound
experience wisdom to people all over the
world I think that probably one of the
top ones if not the top one would be
that idea that everything that happens
is to serve us in some way in the school
and yeah and the picture that I have
from the work I do is a branching tree
as we've talked about and when you take
an action you're always at the base of
that tree right the tree is relative to
you yes so you're standing at the base
of this tree of all your decisions you
could make and all the things that could
happen to you and the choices you make
have to do with the experiences that
you're anticipating having if I
anticipate being healthier a year from
now I'm gonna start making choices that
involve planning a better diet and
shopping for better food and eating that
food and going to the gym because I'm
that's what I'm anticipating
experiencing I'm gonna naturally do
those activities and so if you look at
what you the actions you take at the
base of the tree and you look at all the
branches of the tree that have the
outcome let's say these I can't do it on
the screen but those four and this one
have the apples like these are the ones
that have the experience I want to have
those become heavier and because of
there's four on this branch and only one
over here then this branch becomes
heavier and anything that's on this
branch becomes more likely to happen so
I have situations showing up in my life
to lead me on to this branch mm-hmm and
if we have that picture in mind then
whatever it is that we're acting towards
if we're aligned with our intention yeah
and what we want out of life if those
things are aligned yes actions that are
aligned with that then we can trust that
those apples are lining up and you're
aiming down the possibilities in such a
way that and this is of course
controversial this isn't something
that's been widely accepted but it's
what I try and show that that that
weighs down the branches in a particular
way that bring you more likely bringing
you situations that help you get there
yes still in the path yeah then you can
start to trust okay
whatever showing up in my life is
probably gonna be useful in some way yes
yes it's an excellent excellent way to
to visually describe it so that this
this idea of like you know your whatever
your uniquely here to do as your gift or
your Northstar for you to basically be
in constant check with yourself about
what that is because then that's what
gives you that idea of where your
directional arrow is going towards and
then you're constantly then choosing
decisions and synchronicities arise for
you to get go in that direction more and
more yeah yeah and a lot of times the
things that happened can be obstacles
they can be things that show up that
make us feel insecure you know or make
us feel angry or make us feel hurt and
these are these are those patterns right
from childhood these are the things that
are being triggered in us that make us
want to go one direction but we always
have the choice to how we respond and
yes by choosing to respond differently
over time and stop stop reacting with
anger yeah channel the anger in a
different way or express ourselves
vulnerably instead of being angry you
know anger is not bad it's it's anger
that's directed in the wrong direction
at the wrong person that can cause
wounds and so the more we become handy
with that kind of stuff and more we can
properly handle ourselves under those
yes situations that we've we hurt during
yeah more we're able to catch the
opportunities that are leading us
through flow into better parts of our
lives into up level in our game
which is probably why people give such a
big [ __ ] now about mindfulness and
meditation because they realize now more
than ever in the modern world that the
more that I work on my ability to stay
completely a quantum Aswang massive
stress and anger and all these types of
things arise that the more that I can
vigilantly align myself towards that
Apple on the tree that I actually want
to go towards and so it's a big uh it's
a big it's so meditation and mindfulness
and spirituality are so deeply aligned
with one's ability to make the work with
the decisions that you want at the
branch right time yeah yeah and so in my
book I connect that to flow when we
start paying attention to the situations
that show up in our life when we have
some trust that those situations are
useful in some way then we start to
experience more flow a lot of times
those situations might be obstacles or
problems that show up in our life and
instead of reacting to them we see where
we're being led yeah but it's it's not
about going with the flow and that's a
very important distinction it's this is
about the balance between assertiveness
and receptivity yeah and I I I use a
process it's very simple lor RA X the
lorax and it's listen to the situation
not just to people but to the situation
what's going on here that I need to pay
attention to open my mind so I usually
have a snap judgment about what's going
on and instead of paying attention to
that or doing what it says I can say
okay but maybe there's a different
interpretation of this situation let me
take a minute and this think about it so
then I reflect reflect on the situation
and this is where I start to look at
what are my goals in this situation what
have I been wanting to experience
differently in my life what am i aiming
for professionally that this experience
might actually be helping me towards
let's say I'm going to a meeting and my
boss cancels the meeting and my and I
and I'm supposed to present in that
meeting and I've done all this
preparation while I'm I
be angry about that but then I take a
second estate maybe there's a different
interpretation I started looking and
reflecting on some open-minded
reflection of how this could be good it
turns out that later in the following
week I its rescheduled and somebody
important is in town the CEOs in town
these citizen he or she sits in on the
meeting and so you get this bigger
platform you know in the Hat otherwise
so it's reflecting on how how could this
possibly serve me in ways that I'm not
aware of and then releasing the
attachment because we're always attached
right I thought I was going to do this
presentation today and I have to let
that go because it's not happening and
that allows me to then not be reactive
and angry and then from there I can act
and so this is four steps that have to
do with receptivity and one step that
has to do with with action mmm mmm
proactivity
you know though it's this and then X is
to not give up to keep doing this and
always recognize that there's another
chance coming so there's a lot of
importance in balancing not just going
with the flow not just being receptive
and doing whatever everyone wants
there's an action that's needed some
initiative but it's also starting with
listening and aligning yourself with the
circumstances without being reactive to
them yes
now this I this kind of leads me into
asking you this question because this
word balance is so critical that it's
it's you know we can look back and you
can see it all over ancient spirituality
as well that there's a moment to both be
completely non action-oriented and then
there's a moment to be action-oriented
the receptivity versus the execution and
it happens over and over again in our
lives you know there's that word balance
we can talk about it in so many
different ways to balance between good
and bad or or light and dark or male and
female or in hot and cold I mean it is
literally all over the place and the
question is do you think that that our
creation this one do you think that it
necessarily the one expresses itself
dualistic aliy in this reality giving us
those two polarities and then all of the
nuance in-between wow that's a great
question it's gonna be interpreted so
many different ways so we can just play
with it a little bit one of the things I
love about the author Mihai
Csikszentmihalyi who wrote the book on
flow that I use a lot i reference a lot
of my work in my book and I met him
actually through synchronicity about a
month ago for the first time and he
endorsed my book and that was so huge
and he did he did great work on flow and
the way he talks about it is you know
there's a spectrum you know on one hand
we could take control of the situation
we can exert control we all know how to
take more control of life we also all
know how to throw up our hands in the
air and say I give up I surrender
and some of us do one of the other more
often right and some of us do both at
different times well you might think the
balance is like being in the middle like
I'm gonna halfway throw up my hands in
the air and halfway take control but
that's not it flow is about transcending
that whole spectrum
it's about transcending the worry hmm
recognizing that when you're either in
control or throwing your hands up in the
air and out of control you're still in
both cases you're basically worried
about the situation and trying to figure
out what kind of do to solve this thing
what can I do to get a hold of life and
take some kind of when I throw my hands
in the air I'm actually trying to take
control by giving up control right mMmmm
I give up control maybe things will go
well I'm still trying to get things to
go well what an interesting to put it in
either case I'm worried because I don't
have control over my life the way I want
it and so flow is about transcending the
worry about control recognizing what it
is you're holding on to that's making
you concerned about the situation and
then being able to see what is needed
without that worry getting in the way
your personal ego worried to see what's
needed and then
because in flow there's no right way
there's no like when flow you always do
this the whole point of flow is it it's
never predictable it's only when you
transcend your worry and get out of that
dynamic that you can see Oh in this case
I need to apologize to this person or in
this case I need to hold my ground it
might be different in different
situations interests so in it could it
be then that in in other words that the
the dike the dichotomy between those
polarities it can be a useful way of
interpreting the reality for us to
understand it but the complete flow or
doubt that is occurring when these uh
with the process of the growth the
aliveness the flourishing the evolution
of what this reality really is an our
unique little puzzle piece role in it
there's this balance of complete flown
feeling with the what is my North Star
what is my Apple and how can i what what
what's what's going on at these
bifurcating moments of man I'm being
drawn to go out right now but I also
really want to study or I'm being I have
this opportunity to listen to this
mentors advice versus not so this right
yeah so what's yeah go ahead
so I don't think that there's a right
choice and one of the things that
actually got me started thinking
seriously about synchronicity was this
question I I'm a musician and so I would
sometimes go out and go to a mic or play
play music with people but I was also
doing studying and research and reading
up on the things we're talking about and
had a gun a given night I would be like
what which should I do there's this open
mic but I'm reading this book that I
really want to read and what I would
find is if I go to the open mic I'd have
this experience with people that was
amazing you know and we'd play together
on stage and there'd be this moment and
it comes back to the experience of
awareness we'd have this experience that
was priceless
right yeah never predicted this thing
and yet if I had done something
different and this hadn't happened I
can't imagine my life without this
experience that I just had I love my
music with these people and having a
good time at the same time another night
home and skip that and and do my reading
and I get some insight that would guide
my work for years to come exactly yes so
so clearly there's not a right decision
yes and and what I came to was that the
universe is actually responding to the
choices we make that on this branching
tree whichever choice I make there are
opportunities for well-being on both
images mm-hmm mm-hmm and so there's a
sense of having to like let go of the
attachment to getting it right and us I
might miss out on a great I'm in every
choice I make I'm missing out on great
things on the other branches yes you're
always great things so accepting in
crazy search scenarios like maybe being
prescribed and opioid and getting
addicted and then you know things like
that so that so there's very seriously
like ones that's true yeah where it's
really hard to you know weird we're
talking about such um kind of like
privileged ones where it's like oh
should I go you know or be the play
music um so but on ones where it's maybe
less privileged where it's like oh like
I'm literally about to like nine out of
10 pain level what do I do
opioid or not you know how do I handle
that on yes so stuff like that and then
where that can lead so so there's
there's these they're those are really
difficult questions and it's something I
struggle with a lot recognizing the
limitations of my own upbringing and the
culture that I live in and the community
that I have that's a certain level of
privilege I'm a white male I'm living in
the Bay Area and certain level of
affluence you know I'm somewhere on that
spectrum and I can't see it from a
different person's perspective and I
can't say it's always one thing or the
other I think it's valuable we can't say
that synchronicity is something that
everybody can see all the time in their
life unfolding and I don't want to imply
that we all have access to the same
level of choice we don't you know many
of us have degrees of freedom ours less
yeah for some and more for others yeah
so I think what's really valuable he
is to recognize what degrees of freedom
we have yeah
and allow ourselves to gratitude for
those degrees of freedom yeah yeah yeah
I've gratitude for what choices we have
and see if there's any ways in which
we're blocking a way forward because of
our own inner reactions our own
resentments or your anger or misdirected
feelings of frustration I think we all
carry this levels of negative emotions
that can get in the way of us making
choices that lead us out of danger so I
don't know what it's like to be in a
real dangerous situation and have to
navigate these same things so I don't
want to speak to that but I think that
there's a lot of a lot of progress we
can make even in the simpler situations
that aren't as extreme in how we heal
ourselves from some of those negative
dynamics and I think when we heal
ourselves of anger that we've inherited
from our parents and our their parents
and that we make a difference all the
way down that tree yes future
generations will look back and say at
that time it stopped that pattern
stopped sky healed the transgenerational
trauma that was occurring and then now
Skye's children don't experience that
and they have more degrees of freedom
they have more they and they're not as
susceptible to falling into the same
loops of anger or fear etc sure and I
don't think they don't can solve every
problem you know I don't think that the
goal is to to get things and to have a
certain level of affluence or anything
like that I think that the goal is to
heal grow and evolve you don't can all
we can all do that yes and there's you
know heal grow evolve are fascinating
excellent words and as are we mentioned
one of them a little bit ago gratitude
is another one empathy is huge we were
both mentioning that a moment ago we're
trying to get behind the eyes of other
people in their little tree of
possibilities that then give us a better
understanding and you know humility is
another really important word in that
patience is another very important word
to have patience on the on our on our
journey towards our North Star now I
just really real quick on this one and
then I want to get into a little bit on
the heavier science stuff as we wrap um
one more thought around this is so then
sky we see ourselves as individual
artists there's eight currently there's
eight billion individual artists that
are all in a collective symphony and
that whatever I am going to play as my
next note which can be this bifurcation
you know if it's not one of those severe
ones like an opioid addiction let's say
but if it's one where it's like I'm
gonna go play with my band at a musical
event verse to stay at home and research
and read you can have profound insight
happen from either of those write the
note is just as beautiful from either of
those decisions that you play right yes
that's absolutely true and that you know
I think it opens up IIIi I go into in my
book grief because I think grief is is a
really important emotion that we tend to
push away and we push it away because
it's uncomfortable yeah I'm not saying
that I know what anybody else's grief is
like but I know that for me when I'm
disappointed even in the missed
opportunity
there's a level of grief that's there I
have a section in my book actually that
talks directly about that can I read of
course please read and the link is in
the bio for everyone living in flow our
grief allows us to let go of what is
holding us back from living fully
authentic lives our sorrow and the
outrage that may come with it can light
a fire within us we don't all need to
become activists we don't all need to
follow an outward path of political or
social change rather allowing those
authentic feelings into our hearts can
give us the courage to be honest right
here in our own lives in our own homes
in our own places of work or worship
when we authentically feel our emotions
we are no longer willing to let life go
by without speaking up into the
microphone we're also no longer willing
to let external circumstances our
standards determine who we are
an important first step is allowing
ourselves to feel the grief of loss
whether it's the loss of a relationship
with a person we've loved the loss of
ecosystems or creatures or the loss of a
profession a way of life or an
opportunity when we open to the full
range of our experiences we can also
reconnect with our ability to feel joy
to feel gratitude for what we have and
to sense our power to direct our own
lives it's so truly about again such
something that's both very ancient
advice and very modern coming up again
this idea of you know clean your own
room right tune in word what inner
engineering we you mentioned right there
as you were reading we're constantly
like oh how do I you know fix the world
become the warrior for planet Earth etc
most often by tuning in word and doing
grief work and the amount of time sky
that I've done shitty things in my life
lie she still manipulate in malevolent
ways that I've written down that I've
went and faced I have to face these
things I wrote it I'm facing them all
the time and facing them when they come
up I don't just go berry move on to the
next execution task I actually face that
grief where I'm like wow what was going
on then and how am I going through the
process of consciously healing that to
make sure that I've grown and evolved in
a more light driven pure way and I think
there's a danger in becoming overly
what's called spiritual bypass where
spiritual bypass I think is what happens
when we don't grieve when we grieve our
loss and our sense of you know the
things that we haven't worked out the
way we'd hoped
then it's it allows us to move forward
and change those patterns and not hold
on to those patterns I keep recreating
the situation's yes so well that's nice
when we said yes yes so eloquently said
there um last bit I want to I want to
roll with this with you we talked about
this in our
um previous conversations we were not
recording those I'm really looking
forward to continuing to record these
okay this is gonna get maybe a little
bit abstract and a little bit esoteric
but let's let's hope that we can keep we
can we can both visualize this and share
it with people as we talk about it yeah
okay we've we've talked about what is
called an eternal static timeless non
changing frequency space and that being
known spiritually by some people as in
Akashic records as you've been
describing this or as also being known
as this one unity and then as you've
been describing you've used this word of
Fourier transform you've used those
words before you we've talked about it
how every action that we take were
actually um we're actually making a
choice and then that is um collapsing
that trajectory in the infinite
possibility space so will you please
speak about that interaction between
that one eternal static timeless non
changing frequency space and then our
own Fourier transform choices that
collapse the trajectory in the infinite
possibility space well thank you for
asking that's fun to talk about and
we're gonna to sort of do the really
quick version here and I think it's
important to start by saying and these
are really new ideas and we don't know
what all the connections are what is
fascinating to me after having studied
this for over two decades from a
passionate point of view you know just
me this is like my life question I've
been interested in the Fourier transform
because Fourier transforms allow you to
take a pattern in physical space and
transform it into frequency space and
when you transform it in the frequency
space you may not realize this but
you've totally gotten rid of space
I'm totally gotten rid of time if you
take a music file of sounds vibrating
like an orchestra and you transform it
with a free Fourier transform you now
have a file that has no beginning and
end to low end is the low frequency the
high end is the high frequency where's
the beginning of the song it's not
anywhere specific the song becomes
distributed throughout the whole file
that's a really profound concept we live
our lives orienting through space and
through time we go to the kitchen we get
a snack we talk to our friends who are
across the room from us and they're
separate from us and we're separate
separated by a few feet and that's stuff
that we can make sense of in the Fourier
transformed version of that that that
few feet doesn't have any local
existence it doesn't doesn't make any
sense to talk about those separations so
more than anything I want to bring up
some really important questions when we
start thinking about the world as
information we're talking about signal
processing in Silicon Valley we talk all
about data right big data processing
data in Photoshop but you know you've
taken a photograph i manipulated it to
get rid of certain frequencies or
certain high resolution stuff you can
get rid of it or you can enhance it
these are all things that are being done
in the frequency domain you do that by
transforming the file into the frequency
domain it loses all spatial coordination
you then make a change to the file in
the frequency domain and transform it
back and you get the spatial information
back with some overall changes based on
the thing you changed so if I take a
photograph of a city for instance and I
transform it I get just a bunch of dots
that look like a kind of a weird
spectrum it represents all the patterns
that exist in that photograph the
buildings might be sort of lined up like
this and the patterns are kind of like
there's a pattern left to right of kind
of vertical buildings right mm-hm and
you can kind of see that in the spectrum
it the spectrum captures that
information in a way that you can't
quite tell looks like a bunch of noise
and then if you place a piece of masking
tape you know what they call a mask in
photo editing you place a mask on just
one little section of that file you
erase a small portion of the frequency
space
you leave the rest of the frequency
space intact you don't touch it and you
transform that file back into regular
space what do you think you see
everything is changed the entire picture
has artifacts of waves and shapes in it
that weren't there before so when you
change one small frequences section of
frequency space you change the entire
photograph hmm so there's this there's
this mathematics there that is saying if
frequency space really represents our
physical world which is the bulk of what
I'm trying to propose you do this
Fourier transform both in space and also
in time and like you would for music you
take a music file you can transform it
to its spectrum high frequencies low
frequencies and if you do that then
whatever whatever that is in frequency
space represents all of physical reality
yeah yeah and if a choice is a Fourier
transform
well that's I'm not sure about that okay
I think it's a little more complicated
than yeah every interaction in my in my
work every interaction is a process of
transforming the is the world into
frequency space making a change to its
shape and then transferring it back to
regular space every interaction so when
I bump two particles together a movie
sure that happens when you and I shake
hands boom that happens I mean your
scopic level I'm not sure exactly how to
explain that but at a microscopic level
every interaction is this transform an
inverse okay okay okay now I think I'm
following better so when I when I do
reach out and grab this cup that then I
am the relationship the interaction
between between between what is me in in
the space and time and what is the cup
in this space and time that the infinite
amount of possibility in that frequency
space the the relation there's like a
there's a there's the there's a Fourier
transform that happens for me and the
cup and then the in the inverse how does
yeah how would that yes style of yeah so
first of all these results are published
- they're in review right now and so
what I'm saying is with scientific grain
of salt these are things that we're
talking about that are postulated that
are not understood and you know in
general the idea is the your viewers
probably understand or know that quantum
mechanics is typically thought to be
something that applies just to the
microscopic world and doesn't imply to
their cup for instance mmm-hmm and
that's an interesting there's an
interesting history to that it actually
comes out of history not so much out of
science it comes from the the early
conclusions from quantum mechanics where
that microscopic particles could be in
two places at once like electrons could
go to passive and light have a slit you
know that's not actually true they're
not going through both paths and not
being in two places at once they're it's
a possibility space you know it's more
subtle than that and it turns out that
whenever you look at an electron you get
one or the other when you observe it
quantum mechanics is about what's
happening when you're not looking and
when you observe an electron you get a
certain result you collapse it so but
when we look at the physical world we
when we get on an airplane it's only in
one place at a time right and so we
assume while it's classical it doesn't
obey quantum mechanics but just like the
electron when we observe the airplane
it's in one place so we can't actually
observe something when we're not
observing it so yes so everything behind
me right now is not or in China right
now is in superposition its insulative
to you relative to me and all the
viewers we can see what's there and
there's a certainty oh actually you can
see it too because you're looking at
your screen but this is all about
remember we come back to that rendering
of the virtual reality yes yes are you
yes so this is what's called
relationality where the world takes a
certain shape relative to you and all
that's required is that your view is
consistent with my view when we meet my
consciousness perception is what is
rendering the infinite possibility space
with just you right now our relationship
other than China and what's even until I
grab the cup even the cup which is in my
peripheral vision is has less on more
undetermined in the pot interesting so
the main theory that describes why the
classical world is not quantum
mechanical the reason that we think it's
just like the clock the normal world is
just normal that theory is called
decoherence theory and the in the paper
that proselyte AddThis which is very
well accepted now Zurich the author
writes that we can assume that there's
an objective environment if there's an
objective environment then quantum
mechanics you must not apply it to the
macroscopic world and that's exactly
what isn't true in the in the relational
perspective there's an environment
relative to me and when and and it's
this growing web of interconnections
when I meet our environments meet and
they line up but all that we can say is
this this enhanced web of
interconnections there's not some
objective physical cosmos out there that
were birthing in it's all relative to
our conscious awareness of it and that's
a really huge leap away from what is
generally thought in the mainstream to
be the nature of our reality and we
should take it with a grain of salt but
these are new ideas that are out there
and they're actually supported by
experiment take these with the grain of
salt also but some recent experiments
having to do with observer independence
in quantum measurements and the big
nur's friend paradox there's one
experiment called quantum theory cannot
consistently describe the use of itself
and another called experimental
rejection of observer independence in
the quantum world these do not prove the
relational theory but they support it
they're consistent with it and all the
data that we have from experiment is
actually consistent with this
perspective as far as I understand and
I'll say one more thing that's really
cool when you approach the world through
this holographic formulation when you
look at the world as a hologram what's
cool about Holograms is
they exist as a whole
yeah you're gonna process an image like
a photograph of the city that image
exists as a whole and the patterns in
the whole image get turned into
frequency space in the same way
metaphorically speaking that could be a
metaphor or maybe even exact an example
of this Cup and can also you can take
the Fourier transform of this particular
shape and you get a certain spectrum
that's different than if I cut the top
off and I took that away
that's the spectrum of a half glass
would be different from the spectrum of
a full glass completely different
there's no actual similarity between the
spectrum of two different objects that
are partly different from each other
hmm so there's this way in which the
holographic approach to understanding
the world is dealing with things at a
whole it's not because in quantum
mechanics we're always building from the
ground up we're saying okay quantum
mechanics applies to electrons and if I
put enough electrons together I should
get macroscopic quantum mechanics but I
don't because they collapse but what we
can actually start to question is
whether objects as a whole obey these
properties just like a photograph as a
whole has a certain spectrum these are
really what's the word I'm these are
very new ideas that haven't been shown
to be true but I think they're I've
thought about them a lot and given them
in my writing so I think they're worth
talking about it and so of course open
our minds to these other possibilities
it's it's probably most
it's most abstract to me too
um to understand the all of those
different paper titles that you
mentioned a moment ago it's
um is so important so there's a couple
things here one of them is that the
ideas of of quantum mechanics and the
ideas of a holographic reality those two
things are probably the most like
abstract and hard for me right now to to
grasp in the same amount that this
frequency space and the Fourier
transforms right those kind of like four
things kind of commingling are things
where your way studied and like all
those different papers are being
published in yours as well
I think it's super important for us
collectively to recognize that this is
in the like you know the point one
percenters and that we have to in a
sense we have to come and hug and and
and try and and and and take these as
hypotheses and further try and do more
tests on if these things are the actual
way of what is of what the reality is
it's so paramount to warmly welcome
whereas is so much of the time we just
just say get out of here nonsense so
that's why I write as an author because
I think it's important not just to leave
these in academic papers but to say
here's here's the conclusion I draw from
the holographic discussion we just had
that instead of in the moment life
existing in the moment you're existing
on a timeline yes you Fourier transform
everything there's a wholeness to
history history doesn't exist as you
moving along a you know the present
moment from moment to moment and yeah
that's do good you're on a timeline that
has a beginning and an end and you're
choosing between the different possible
timelines and this has an impact on how
likely you are then to think about
what's your long-term vision vision and
what are the circumstances that are
showing up in your path to help you to
that vision this is where you and I
definitely this is our most synergistic
area of
study for us to is the is the idea of of
the tree of possibility and the birth to
death in a North Star and all the
bifurcating moments and having foresight
and vision and choice to want to go in
in the direction that is what your
unique gift and inner artist can express
in the world and then okay and just on
on a very on a very kind of last thought
around this is I want I want as much of
this cutting edge thinking
all the way from the tree of possibility
where we were at initially to the
complexity of the holographic quantum
mechanic reality that you were
describing I want people to begin
endeavoring into understanding it even
at the most get even at the most surface
level thinking about our lives as the
tree of possibility in the bifurcations
thinking about as we mentioned at the
very beginning going back and studying
for weeks at a time
ancient spiritualities of the world and
what they were thinking comparatively
with the holographic quantum mechanics
and Fourier transforms that you're
talking about now and really really
really trying to begin to piece and
understand that's why we're doing this
conversation and what recommendations
give some book recommendations let's do
that okay so a book that got me started
was the dancing wooly masters by Gary
Zhukov and that's for non-scientists who
want to understand that what quantum
mechanics why it's profound what it's
really pointing towards in a profound
sort of way towards the Eastern
spirituality another book that's more
advanced for people who feel really
comfortable with more technical stuff
that aren't physicist is the strange
story of the quantum by Benesh Hoffmann
and then the book by David Bohm called
wholeness in the implicit order was was
pretty good and there's others but let's
stick with that I love that and of
course living in flow by Scott Nelson
Isaacs as well yeah I love I love these
recommendations these years super-super
also to look into our episode that we've
recorded with Seth caustic that's on our
channel as well would highly recommend
looking into that as well and I know you
two are working closely together which
is very exciting and there's a lot more
to unpack on our next conversations that
I'm really looking forward to sky this
has been yeah such an honor and a
pleasure always
yeah thanks Alan it's great to be here
thanks set for getting us together and I
look forward to next time yeah likewise
and let's go ahead and also give your
the the YouTube channel website website
and YouTube channel are kind of the main
spots right now right for you along with
the book yeah so I have a course that I
just launched called the living in flow
course which dives into some of the ways
that you can use tools of flow and
synchronicity to see the goals in your
life and how to adapt and move around
the resistance that you might have and
get back into flow you can find that at
my website Skye Nelson comm and the URL
for that is also you thrive here that's
the letter you thrive here comm slash
living in flow you can find me on
youtube under Skye Nelson I love it
all those links are gonna be in the bio
everyone I love it Wow whoo it's so
fascinating seeing what cutting-edge
science and its harmonization with the
ancient spirituality around the nature
of reality this is my favorite my
favorite big ask questions and fields
that's what gravitates us so much
together I'm really pumped and looking
forward to our continued co-creation so
biggest man appreciated always and we're
gonna do more in person as well I'm
looking forward to those two okay so
thank you very much all right bye
everyone thank you for tuning in we
really appreciate it we'd love to hear
your thoughts in the comments below an
episode ooh let us know what you're
thinking about this awesome episode of
the sky and check out all the links in
the bio below disguise work go and
support him check out all those links in
his course in his book and also go and
build the future everyone manifest your
dreams into a world we love you very
much thank you for tuning in we will see
you soon everyone much love peace
boom I love it
that's great I love it thanks man great
questions great conversation
[Music]